[Music]
take
[Music]
we are a circus of big family tradition
and with the way we present our show is
the same way that my family presented
the show over 175 years ago
there's nothing fancy about what we do
here
it's magic
real magic
[Music]
when you grow up in a circus as a child
you just step into being a clown
welcome to the circus thank you for
coming we're a classic family circus
which means our families here working
together performing together would you
like to meet some of our family
first of all is my mother the matriarch
of our family then i have my sister
carla who with her husband rudy they
performed with her dog act and then we
have my sister tosca she has the horses
on the show but she also directs the
show
her husband jay is an amazing white
clown the white clown is the stray clown
he's the best white clown that i've ever
seen
the act that my son and i do right now
in a show is actually a balloon routine
it's nothing new i mean it's thousands
of years old clowns have been doing it
forever
it happens to be really cute when he
does it because he's adorable
it's an it's an
unexplainable thing to see my child
do what he loves to do
i mean i get this seven-year-old
beautiful little boy
his heart opens up and he gives it
to everybody
[Music]
it's different here i think than most
places when we come into this ring we
become family
i believe circus and family are
basically the same words
[Music]
we didn't really have any fast attackers
from texas until he came along
like i couldn't really believe my eyes
like i was in shock his hands like they
were always moving and it was like there
was no like thinking about where to put
it it was just like a non-stop just like
he's off the charts he's like as fast as
a lightning bolt
[Music]
my name is trey griffith and i am the
fastest cup sector in the state of texas
my goal is to be the fastest cup sector
in the whole entire world
when i first saw trey
begin cup stacking
i was thrilled
kids on the spectrum are always very
passionate and very intense on what
their fixation is
and he just shined i mean you could see
that he was in his element he was
comfortable
he was alive and
he was just doing his thing
trey took it to a completely different
level he was doing it systematically
instead of just kind of for fun and it
was all about getting that next best
time
what trey does in five or six seconds
takes me 10 or 12 13 seconds
we've learned not to
ever discount what he says he's going to
do
sport stacking
is
using a set of
12 plastic cups and you stack them in a
very specific sequence of pyramids
and you are racing yourself and you're
racing a time room
it's a sport that you don't have to be
tall you don't have to necessarily be
able to run quickly as long as you've
got the 12 cups you've got a mat and
you've got a timer you can stack
[Music]
to me
it's just mind-boggling to see these
stackers like trey and his friends and
you can tell they're not even looking at
the cups that they're stacking it is all
muscle memory i mean it's so fast when
they get to this level that
the naked eye cannot see it all
[Music]
when i found out that i was having a boy
of course i thought about
when i was a boy and playing catch with
my dad in the backyard and you flash
forward
you know thinking about those types of
things with your kiddo
but when trey
found stacking that's like okay cool
here is a sport that he's into and it's
got speed i've always loved sports with
speed and it's got rhythms which make
him happy and i realized what a better
way to bond with my child than to learn
how to stack myself i get to stand next
to my son who's one of the fastest in
the world
and stack with him and be a part of
something special
watching the two of them stack together
are probably some of the best moments
i've ever had
our motto has always been the family
that stacks together stays together
we go to these tournaments together
we've traveled together we've made
friends all over the country all over
the world i mean it's definitely
enriched our lives
[Music]
i'm pops the mentor
i'm nicole paris
the princess
beatboxing is just simply making sounds
with your mouth making music with your
mouth
when beatbox came to saint louis in the
early 80s it was always about emulating
what the dj did so i just started
perfecting my skill as i got older and
then
my wife she gets pregnant with nicole so
i would be bots up against the belly and
nikola start twisting so you will see my
wife belly almost like boom
she liked it she thought it was funny
and cute and then as nicole got bigger
in the belly it wasn't cute no more at
the age of 13 was my first talent show i
just went home and i said pops i just
joined the talent show you're gonna
teach me how to beatbox he taught me how
to hold the mic taught me how to breathe
taught me the basic beat i went to the
talent show did that they made me mad at
the talent show they was clapping off
beat
and it was like
i then started to add my own thing to
what he taught me one night i came home
from work and as i'm walking in the door
i heard her making all these strange
noise i had to tell him like that's not
beatboxing no i don't do that that's
corny i was like
what
this is when i had to realize and tell
myself look this is what she wants to do
me and pops we be boxed anywhere all day
don't even make a difference no it
really don't be boxed by cooking
barbershop
when we're ready to beatbox it literally
happens doesn't matter if you go to her
youtube channel you will see us sitting
down beatboxing into some folks and it
can look like a competition oh my god
we're not really battling it's just this
just jam session just us having fun this
this is how i bond with my child even
though even though 160 million people be
like
pop loser
i want her to be the best i want her to
to out do me not and i'll do me like as
in a battle but i want her to just just
continue to grow and add to beatboxing
[Music]
two and a half hours outside of seattle
in this sleepy little town of yakima
washington lies a hidden empire and what
they've been making you've used your
entire life it's like one of those
things that you go
oh my god i didn't that that was
invented oh yeah wow
my name is stephanie and i'm the oldest
of the paxton women
my name is kimberly and i'm in the
middle
my name is melissa and i am the baby
[Music]
we are the three sisters behind the
quick lock corporation and the little
bag closures that you see just about
everywhere
and by everywhere she means everywhere
typically around bread
but it can be found on a variety of
packages from produce to
potatoes we sell billions of quick locks
a year
billion
[Laughter]
the invention of the little closures
that could dates back to their
grandfather floyd paxton the story
certainly is that our grandfather
whittled his first quick clock out of a
credit card whether or not that is
actual fact will probably never be
discovered but the bad closure business
isn't all fun and games i would say our
biggest competition is the wire tie
you know the thing that you know the
twist that you can't untwist or get it
all mixed up oh yeah those things never
thought about it but if we're being
honest i guess i never really thought
about back closures in general
it's always so fun telling the story of
the quick lock it's this little plastic
square closure that was invented in
yakima washington and has gone from this
little town to being sold globally and
internationally
[Music]